so steve steve and i watched top gun
with an audience and steve was right in
front of me so i got to watch the way
steve's body reacted to this movie this
was the guy who was crying at every no
no
i want to respond to all this but i have
questions so let me just jump in and say
i could i could dig deep on that um uh
as i've said repeatedly i love this
movie um it's just so fantastic i just
want to get that out there on camera um
but glenn i want to start an individual
question i read and could be wrong that
uh originally you were not going to play
hangman and it was tom that convinced
you to take on the role is that true
that is absolutely true yeah i
originally auditioned for miles teller's
role uh for the role of rooster
um
and in hindsight uh you know obviously
it it's uh it's sometimes a bummer not
to be chosen but i gotta say
miles smokes it in this movie he's just
so good and such the embodiment of what
goose was in the first one you when you
see him on screen you're like
i mean
it really feels like you're you're
watching goose it's it's incredible and
so tom you know after not getting that
role i i
uh tom convinced me
that he was gonna build out another
character for me
because the character was on the page
just didn't really feel like something i
was interested in and then tom really
sat down with me for a couple hours
first off he showed me uh how we were
actually going to be in the back of f18s
which was a very big selling point and
then we got to talk about life and
career and um to sit down with your hero
um
and then have him become your mentor
and tell him how he makes movies how he
develops movies and how he's built the
career he's built
and has entertained audiences for four
decades it's
um i couldn't pass up that opportunity
i'm really glad i didn't and and i i
mean you can't picture i don't know if
the roles would have been reversed with
miles plays hangman and you play uh uh
rooster but he plays a fantastic hey man
i can't see anybody else playing taking
on that role you've done a great job
with it and i think you i mean you're
one of my favorite characters i'm not
just saying that because we're partners
or anything but
oh i appreciate that yeah i know
i gotta say this is a movie i've wanted
to make my whole life and
seeing what it became as you've seen how
incredible this thing is i would have
been really bummed to have seen this
movie and to have missed out on this
opportunity for both of you um i view
tom cruise as like the goat of these
kinds of like he he's just on another
level and i'm curious for both of you
what was it like working day in and day
out with him what did you take away from
the experience that will like take with
you to every future project
anything is possible you know when
people say that that you you can't do
this you can't do that tom finds a way
and he wouldn't take no for an answer
and uh
you know timing is everything like he
could have made the second top gun you
know right after the the success of the
first one but he chose like no that's
not the right time man i think you know
he truly waited for me to be born to
make this top gun but
yeah yeah um no no uh honestly i i think
uh uh
you know just finding a way to do it and
we've done things in an aircraft that
will never be done again uh first first
people to do it and i'm thankful for
that i think that's also another lesson
to take away from tom is is
this idea that movies don't make
themselves they're
he is so aware of what every department
is doing it's a true team sport yeah
he's
he he and he cares about how he looks on
camera how i look on camera what we're
doing the minutia of what makes a movie
great and that relentless pursuit of
perfection
is what aggregates to make a great movie
iconic and right yeah and i think tom is
a guy that we've learned from in the
fact that that guy does not rest on his
laurels he's the greatest movie star of
all time and there's a reason and
there's a reason he wakes up every day
he's at set before anyone else he's
going through the script he's talking to
people making sure we're safe up in jets
that we're all prepared for whatever
we're doing and and um it's that level
of care that makes a great friend but uh
you know a great leader
on that note i already have to stop i'm
gonna say again i love this movie hope
it's a huge hit for you guys enjoy the
world premiere in san diego thank you
good to see you my man good to see you
later